bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va se
demander si adam et eve ont vraiment
existé
alors rassurez vous il va pas être
question de considérations religieuses
ou créationnistes dans cette vidéo dont
on va parler de génétique humaine et on
va voir que en un certain sens adam et
eve ont vraiment existé juste ils sont
jamais connu
c'est une chose que vous savez
certainement déjà l'information
génétique elle est contenue dans les
chromosomes et nous les humains on a 23
paires de chromosomes alors je dis bien
pire puisque on a tous deux exemplaires
de chaque chromosome deux exemplaires
sauf que il ya une exception à cette
règle c'est la 23ème père ce qu'on
appelle les chromosomes sexuels
vous savez les femmes possèdent une
paire de chromosomes x mais les hommes
possèdent un chromosome x et un
chromosome y
du coup elle chromosome y quand il est
là il est toujours tout seul dans son
genre il n'est jamais associé dans une
vraie paire et ya une conséquence
intéressante de ça c'est que mon
chromosome y c'est exactement le même
que celui de mon père
et ça c'est pas vrai des autres
chromosomes 1 prenons par exemple je
sais pas moi le chromosome 10 est mon
père possède deux exemplaires du
chromosome 17 dans chacune de ces
cellules un exemplaire hérité de son
propre père et un hérité de sa mère
et lors de la production des
spermatozoïdes mais ça marcherait pareil
pour les ovules
il se produit un mécanisme qui va
mélanger ces deux chromosomes de manière
aléatoire
on appelle ça la recombinaison génétique
la conséquence de ça c'est que le
chromosome 17 que je reçois de mon père
il est unique il est différent des siens
il est aussi différente ceux de mes
grands parents et c'est ça le principe
du brassage génétique et ce mécanisme de
recombinaison il existe pour tous les
chromosomes sauf le chromosome y
puisqu'ils la personne avec qui ce
mélange est le chromosome y
du coup mon père m'a passé son
chromosome y à l'identique et il l'a pas
c'est aussi à mon frère qui du coup a
exactement le même chromosome y que moi
mais du coup ce chromosome y
c'est aussi le même que celui de mon
grand-père évidemment et de mes oncles
et de mes cousins et aussi de mes
cousins au deuxième degré p&c se serait
assez tentant de conclure que tous les
hommes de la planète doivent posséder
exactement le même promo somme y
mais en fait c'est pas tout à fait vrai
la raison c'est à cause des mutations
génétiques dans nos cellules il ya des
mutations qui se produisent de manière
aléatoire et qui modifie légèrement la
séquence de notre adn
et donc on n'a pas tous exactement le
même chromosome y
alors ces mutations elles sont
relativement rares on estime qu'entre
deux frères il doit y avoir en moyenne
en gros une mutation de différence sur
le chromosome y
une mutation sur plusieurs dizaines de
millions de base et du coup entre moi et
mes cousins bas il ya en moyenne environ
deux mutations de différence et puis
avec mes cousins au deuxième degré en
moyenne trois mutations alors j'insiste
tout ça c'est en moins
c'est à dire que c'est soumis aux lois
du hasard ce qui est intéressant c'est
que si on prend deux hommes au pif dans
la population et qu on compte le nombre
de différences sur leur chromosome y
ça nous donne une idée de à quel degré
ils sont reliés dans la généalogie et si
on fait ça pour tout un échantillon
représentatif de la population mondiale
actuelle on peut avoir une idée de à
quel degré on est tous cousins ou bien
une autre manière de le dire combien de
générations nous sépare de notre ancêtre
commun en ligne directe et si on fait
ces analyses
et là je le dis comme si c'était facile
en fait ce n'est pas du tout on trouve
que le mâle humain ancêtres en ligne
directe de tous les mâles humains vivent
à l'heure actuelle il aurait vécu il ya
environ 150 millions et c'est cet
individu qu'on appelle adam chromosome y
alors ce type d' analyse on peut la
faire aussi avec les femmes mais pour la
faire on va pas utiliser le chromosome x
puisque le chromosome x
il vient en perd c'est à dire qu'il va
subir une recombinaison et être
complètement modifiée à chaque
génération
on va utiliser autre chose qu'on appelle
l'adn mitochondrial les mitochondries ce
sont des petits trucs mais en fait on
dit des organites qu'on trouve dans
presque toutes les cellules et qui sont
en quelque sorte les centrales
énergétiques de la cellule et ce qui est
amusant c'est que les mitochondries elle
se comporte un peu comme une cellule
dans la cellule
elles sont capables de se diviser et
elles ont leur propre adn qui se
réplique mais qui est distinct de l'adn
normal qu'on trouve dans le noyau des
cellules
sssa l'adn mitochondrial alors ce qui
est intéressant pour nous c'est que vos
mitochondries au départ elles
proviennent entièrement de l'ovule de
votre mère
au cours de la fécondation normalement
le spermatozoïde ne file pas de
mitochondries
donc si vous êtes un homme votre adn
mitochondrial il ira pas plus loin que
ça
par contre si vous êtes une femme cet
adn mitochondrial que vous avez hérité
de votre mère il passera à vos enfants
et notamment à vos filles qui le
passeront à leur fille qui le placeront
à leurs filles
et c est donc l'adn mitochondrial il se
transmet intégralement de mère en fille
de la même manière que le chromosome y
se transmettait intacte de père en fils
sauf que comme pour le chromosome y
la transmission elle n'est pas parfaite
il ya des mutations dans l'adn
mitochondrial est donc on peut faire le
même genre d' analyse que tout à l'heure
et ça nous amène à conclure que toutes
les femmes du monde
vivante à l'heure actuelle elle
descendants en ligne directe d'une femme
qu'on appelle eve mitochondrial
et qui aurait vécu il ya environ 150
mille ans bon donc on à adam eve et il
aurait vécu tous les deux il ya cent
cinquante mille ans est-ce que non mais
je vous arrête tout de suite c'est pas
du tout ce que vous croyez et on va voir
pourquoi
il faut bien comprendre un truc dans
cette affaire il n'y a absolument aucune
raison pour que la dent chromosome y
élève mitochondrial d'une se soient
rencontrés a eu des enfants et même de 2
et simplement vécu au même moment
alors pour illustrer ça on va prendre un
arbre généalogique que simplifiée alors
pour qu'ils soient pas trop compliqué il
va être un petit peu incestueux mais
vous allez voir ça change rien aux
raisonnements sur cet arbre super simple
vous voyez des hommes en bleu et des
femmes en rouge et il ya un homme qui
est là dans chromosome y de cet arbre
c'est à dire l'ancêtre de tous les mâles
de la ligne du bas en ligne directe
paternel alors voilà celui-ci et on a
aussi une sève
c'est elle qui est l'ancêtre en ligne
directe maternelle cette fois de toutes
les femmes de la dernière génération
et oui et qu adam et eve dans cet
exemple là ils n'ont pas été en couple
ils n'ont pas eu d'enfant ils sont pas
rencontrés et ils ont même pu vivre à
des milliers de kilomètres de distance
voire carrément à des époques
différentes
et là j'ai pris un arbre très simple
mais on peut très facilement construire
des exemples où adam et eve sont séparés
par plusieurs centaines de générations
d'ailleurs les datations que je vous ai
donné en fait elles sont pas si précise
que ça pour la danse y croient qu'on
estime en ce moment que c'est entre 120
et 160 mille ans et puis pour lev
mitochondrial c'est plutôt entre 100 et
150 millions
alors quand même le fait qu'on date la
dent y élève mitochondrial d'à peu près
la même période s'est pas complètement
surprenant cette période elle correspond
à l'émergence de notre espèce homo
sapiens mais avant sa sortie d'afrique
alors pour tout ça je vous renvoie à ma
vidéo sur le sujet pour bien comprendre
la différence entre ces individus qu'on
a appelée adam et eve et leurs
homologues biblique il ya plusieurs
choses à noter la première c'est que
adam y était pas du tout le seul homme
de son temps
de même est venu tôt contre ia n'était
pas du tout la seule femme de son temps
d'ailleurs à dents y avait un père et
est venu tôt qu'on dréal avait une mère
et puis surtout il faut bien comprendre
que ces individus ce ne sont pas des
individus fixe absolue on a dit ce sont
les ancêtres en ligne directe des hommes
et des femmes qui sont vivants à l'heure
actuelle et donc leur identité va varier
en fonction de la population vivant à un
moment donné si demain toute la
population mondiale moeurs sauf moi et
mes cousins
eh ben mon grand père devient la dent y
l'ancêtre en ligne directe de tous les
hommes vivent en plus de ça il faut voir
que là dedans y élève mitochondrial ce
ne sont pas les seules manières de nous
définir un ancêtre commun
là on a parlé des ancêtres communs en
ligne directe paternel est en ligne
directe maternelle mais on peut très
bien parlé de notre ancêtre commun le
plus proche tout court regardez sur mon
schéma même si adam et la sève est ici
les ancêtres communs à la dernière
génération qui soient les plus récents
et bien ce sont 1
ils sont plus récents que adam y élève
mitochondrial et si on prend la
population humaine actuelle dans son
ensemble
on estime que notre ancêtre commun le
plus récent il pourrait avoir seulement
quelques milliers d'années
ça veut dire qu'il a existé un individu
qui vivait probablement autour du
néolithique et dont tous les êtres
humains actuellement vivant sur terre
descendent alors attention ils
descendent pas que lui loin de là mais
en quelque sorte on en a tous un petit
morceau
enfin le paradoxe c'est que à cause du
phénomène de recombinaison il est
possible que au final presque aucun des
gènes de cet individu ne soit parvenue
jusqu'à nous alors que finalement la
dent chromosome y élève mitochondrial
qui vivait il ya bien plus longtemps
ils nous ont légué plus ou moins intact
leur chromosome y est leur adn
mitochondrial et qui sait peut-être que
vous êtes là dedans y soulève
mitochondrial de l'humanité qui peuplera
la terre dans cent cinquante mille ans
enfin pour ça va falloir se mettre au
boulot quand même merci d'avoir suivi
cette vidéo si elle vous a plu n'hésitez
pas à la partager notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux pour m'aider à faire
connaître la chaîne vous pouvez suivre
les actus la chaîne sur facebook ou sur
twitter ce qu'ils souhaitent peuvent me
soutenir ce type i comme d'habitude
j'aurais la liste de tous les types
heures à la fnac
et vous pouvez aussi aller voir mon
bouquin qui est sorti chez flammarion
merci et à bientôt